in the lobby of Ramsey solutions
dropping by is John and ELISA hi guys
how are you alright
good welcome where do you guys live we
live in Rochester Indiana it's called
the South Bend yeah what brings you to
Nashville we're actually on our way back
from Gulf Shores Alabama and we knew you
were in in the studio today so we
thought if we could ask our question
that God was leading us to ask this Wow
very cool okay so what's up um my wife
has a genetic disease called
Huntington's disease and it it will
essentially incapacitate her around
retirement age for us we've seen her her
mom and her grandma and both of her
aunts go through the process and so
we're we're in a really good place
thanks to your program we're debt-free
except for the house we've we've saved
twenty thousand dollars for our son's
college already
Wow we're you know we're where we need
to be but we're not putting the whole 15
percent for retirement we just we don't
know how what do we do for for
retirement how much do we focus on that
knowing that we want to live like no one
else
mm-hmm but we won't have that
opportunity together most likely so we
just want to know what your opinion is
on what we need to do to you know should
we should we just hammer it and and just
go through it and say you know we're
just gonna do it or should we
what is your household income just over
ninety thousand okay that's good news it
was at five years ago about the same
we're teachers so okay okay we'll make
this the rest of our life problem okay
good the arm hmm well I think it would
be a bad idea to do all one and not the
other whatever that is in other words if
you save zero right for retirement
that's gonna leave you eating Alpo okay
that's not a plan and so we don't want
to and you know quote enjoy the day
unquote and knowing that you know what
you've got a fairly
predictable outcome here and you've got
you know some track record with family
to verify it really it's not just a
vague worry that it might be this way or
might be that way I'll give you an
example I've got a friend of mine that
was diagnosed with MS a while back in
fact I have two friends were diagnosed
with MS one of them is down and not
doing well and the other ones fully
functional and has gone on for a decade
with it and it hasn't affected so you
know you just that's a little different
than your situation your sounds like I
don't know anything about the disease
I'm not medical but obviously but I mean
I'm just listening to you you're you're
not you know you're you've got it fairly
clarified as to what the outcome looks
like so I'm gonna do both in some way or
another if you have to cut back from 15
and you do ten you still retire with
dignity and you get to do some travel or
something while you can then yeah that's
fine
I may look at cutting some other areas
so that I could still do those two
things the travel or the enjoyment
quote-unquote with money and the others
but in other words I might not eat out
as much I might not buy that that car or
whatever that you could normally do in
the math but you're trying to say no
we're going to enjoy this we're going to
enjoy that and we want to be wise about
retirement so some kind of a balance in
there and maybe it's not just those two
things you're choosing from maybe you
look it back up and look at the whole
budget and go okay well we can't not
because we're facing this we're really
not gonna do that thing over there that
additional but I can put the pool in the
backyard or whatever that thing is right
or I don't know what it is right or do
that thing that just did I just hit it
oh my god you know you can see what I'm
saying you got this other thing laying
over here this may be a third thing that
you can get into you've got these two
things juxtapositions against each other
retirement or quote enjoy life while you
can
unquote and maybe there's a third thing
or a fourth thing down in the budget
that you can make some other choices on
and still be able to do that but there's
no I'm not legalistic about it I came up
with 15% because I ran the numbers on a
huge slew of incomes on a huge slew of
Ages and it works almost every time you
know for somebody but obviously
if you're 70 and you start saving for
retirement start saving 15% and you save
zero up until then it's not going to
work but or if you make $10,000 a year
for your whole life it's not going to
work so extreme situations but there's
no magic to the 15 versus 12 or 10 or 9
the point is do something substantial
and given your diagnosis in your
situation balance it out yeah so yeah I
mean I I mean I would just be crunching
those numbers and watching for raises
and looking for opportunities to pick up
tutoring or something to be able to fund
something else or do that you know
always think of the guy that made me cry
one day he delivered pizzas for for a
whole year just because he was a teacher
and he could not figure out a way to
fund his kids college fund and so he
delivered pizzas for a whole year took
all that money and there was a baby and
set the money aside when he was done so
he didn't go okay I can't fund college I
got to do this and I'm not saying you
need to go deliver pizzas but my point
is there's always another way to look at
the thing and go what else can we give
up in order to get this goal because
those are both valid goals and they're
not necessarily competing head-to-head
is what I'm trying to say so I bless you
when what you're facing thank you and
with what you're you know your courage
to to go forward with that when did you
get the diagnosis good I'm like I don't
know five or six years ago okay so
you've been living with this away yeah
yeah I meant a lot to her to know for it
not to be I like to know things oh yeah
yeah and she's the planner you know like
we're looking at you you know John can
just needs enough retirement to you know
keep the air conditioning on and play
video games could be outlawed by the
yeah but change changing our family tree
that's a big deal for us that we wanted
we wanted to do that for Tyson and and
be and be different and and be able to
do those things but and I think you can
you make enough money to be able to do
that and to enjoy your life along the
way you're young enough that you've got
and you've done really well today
I mean you've hit all this marks today
so you're doing fine you're gonna be
able to pull it off
but doc my point is I want to set you
free from any kind of quote-unquote Dave
Ramsey legalism on the 15 percent it's
just not that way it's not that and and
so you've got to use you've good use
you've used good common sense to this
point and it may have been very
disciplined and have accomplished a lot
of your goals and I think you're gonna
hit these goals as well I think you're
gonna be fine
thanks for stopping by thank you god
bless hey you guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey
show and did you know that I have my
very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the same
room to channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you